- Ce geste n'est désormais plus
obligatoire pour emprunter les
transports en commun au Québec.
- Il était temps!
- Et, cela en ravit plus d'uns.
- Ça fait longtemps qu'on le
fait, les autres places l'ont
enlever il y a longtemps, fa
que là maintenant qu'on l'a
enlevé aussi, ça fait du bien.
- Sentiment partagé du côté de
Québec.
- Maintenant, on va entrer dans
l'autobus, pas le masque, en
tout cas, j'aime beaucoup.
- Il reste, toutefois, des
sceptiques face à ce nouvel
assouplissement.
- Dans le métro, je le mets,
il y a trop de monde.
- Je vais quand même aux heures
e le garder dans
le wagon.
- Je considère que nous n'avons
pas encore totalement fini cette
phase que nous traversons depuis
deux ans, donc je préfère encore
garder mon masque un petit peu.
- Le port du masque est
obligatoire au Québec depuis
bientôt deux ans. Mais pour
certainsdéjà chose du
passé.
- Ça faisait quelques jours que
je ne le mettais pas.
e ne porte déjà plus
le masque depuis longtemps
- Le mois dernier, il à été
levé pour les lieux publics
comme lents,
les salles de spectacle et
les centres sportifs.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
Santé et Services sociaux Québet
la dernière, c'était la dernière
et on est très content de cela
parce que la situation le
permet.
- Le masque demeurs
obligatoire pour les centres
hopitaliers, les CHSLD, les CLSC
et les cliniques médicales.
LIONEL BERTHOUX, prof. maladies
infectieuses Univ. Qc à Trois-R.
- Ça aurait pu avoir lieu plus
tôt, cette fin du masque
obligatoire dans les transports
en commun. Ça fait longtemps
qu'on est passé à une autre
phase de la pandém
laquelle les mesures collectives
de prévention ont de moins en
moins de sens et il convient
maintenant de faire des actions
plus ciblées auprès despopulatis
vulnérables.
- La santé publique fédérale
prévient que ce n'est pas une
raison pour baisser la garde.
Dr HOWARD NJOO, admin. en chef
adjoint santé publique Canada- t
les sous-lignés comme le BA.4 et
5, et ce qu'on voit
actuellement, c'est que
le pourcentage des dépistages et
résultats qui sont a
augmenté.
- Il n'écarte pas une
recrudescence des cas, cet été.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Mon